on the screen and in character right now
yeah who's the bad kisser Jon Snow hands
that's really a tough call
welcome back to glamour with me joshing
tonneaus and today we are joined by the
hand with more force than anyone in the
galaxy it's Amelia claw how are you very
well very well thank you we were just
saying about how obsessed I am about
your hair keep on that it's just wrong
yeah it's it's like a it's a whole thing
luckily I'm still filming the show so
the amazing hair department on Game of
Thrones
yeah Jimmer eats when I need him as soon
as we're done I'm actually having fear
factor about like what am I gonna do
when you went onto this film set and
knew you were going to the hair
department for the first time and they
were like here's your hair look be like
where's my buns the hair got a lot of
airtime
it was a lot of like let's not have like
that's to layer so yeah we had to
navigate the hair space delicately it's
a difficult search it's very difficult
to write that needle chiona mean a lot I
went to get some tips from you about
being more Star Wars in everyday life
okay so I've got a couple little
scenarios excellent pinyon all right
I'll do what I can
I've been a solo act for quite a while
okay and Chewy's given me a call and
he's like hey let's make a duo right
he's put on the table a couple of songs
I just want to get your opinion on which
one I should go for okay can't chew this
chew it real good oh I like it I love
that one or no tears left to chew yeah
um I would say I'd say chew it real good
yeah to chew it real good chew chew chew
chew it real good yes I mean is there
some sort of like great like Star Wars
inspired dance me definitely cheese for
that just like that yeah it's the kind
like the lightsabers at the same time
exactly exactly exactly also when you're
dancing with someone new
ten for EM you know you need to be able
to like work every yeah whatever angle
you just place to use him is like a
really tall pole I'm just picturing the
same hmm and that's he like schooled you
in wiki uh I should be really good at
whoopee by now cuz yonas who plays
Chewie
yeah is on set you know you obviously
you they do a lot of stuff in post so
like make fur sounds is truthful yes
it's possible but on set he was pretty
amazing out and everybody else seems to
be able to do great Chewie
Barbara me there have been a lot of boy
dramas on my shed
okay nightmare and I really fancy the
pilot but my alpha K pilot really
fantasies him as well what's a girl to
do I mean do you know what I just how
close are you with the copilot mmm
obviously we caught more like frenemies
Oh even better
yeah that's fine you just need to know
if the pilot is into you or into the
copilot yeah maybe you know you could
sabotage the pilot in some way mm-hmm or
just maybe if your frenemies and the
copilot isn't that nice anyway so if you
really let the pilot then the pilot
should be exactly this would be part
yeah it should be our season should be
like you don't wanna go with their babes
because he's mine yes on the screen and
then character right now yeah it's the
bad kisser Jon Snow hands oh oh oh
that's really a tough call it's like to
be a to be a lead male actor these days
you just gotta like be excellent at
kissing yeah
so there's for your goods yeah
[Music]